ce que je fais je sais pas mais qu'est
ce que tu fais je ne sais pas tu vas
devoir ouais mais je vous fais un tour
de magie où je peux te faire un tour de
magie
oui tant la colère de me faire un tour
oui je viens te salue aujourd'hui je
suis avec raphaël callandreau alias
raffoux ouais bon soir il a une
éloquence très particulière raphaël
caceres rappelle qu'à l'endroit et moi
on travaillait on s'est rencontrés du
moins sur lui pour l'association rire
pour guérir very good way je te
principalement dessous deux artistes et
artistiques musicales musicales
principalement le raf ou choquer vous
pouvez voir il ya deux ans voilà donc
plutôt cinq essais pas concerné en rien
les cheveux longs voilà c'est vrai je
n'avais pas de moustache mais je n'ai
toujours pas
j'accompagne guillaume d'arnaud au piano
sur ses solos guillaume d'arnaud mais
c'est pas celui qu'on a vu dans la vidéo
de demain
extrait tout le monde est petit 6 a
touché les deux vidéos même temps et je
les remets ça serait
c'est comme s'il a par exemple ont été
au bout ce martin exactement où il joue
d'ailleurs
oui oui c'est vrai que c'est grâce à
facebook répondu pas du tout
portera je devais le mentaliser je
devais lui faire un petit truc en fait à
la foule mais il m'a il m'a dit là il ya
quelques secondes je mettrai le rush il
m'a dit est ce que tu veux je te fasse
un tour mais évidemment évidemment que
je préfère vont passer des tours j'ai
366 vidéo à faire cette année donc si un
mec veut bosser à ma place il ya pas de
problème je vous mets à la place des mes
yeux à moi on est tout ouïe radio fm en
euros un joyau de ça c'est l'objectif
alors oui regardez si west alors bonjour
aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre à
enlever votre pouce parce que voilà on
croit que le pouce est attaché mais moi
je peux le détacher
je vais pas vous apprendre à le faire je
vais vous montrer quand je voulais faire
faites donc attention là je prends up et
là attention parce que vous voyez là
j'ai pris mon seront pris dans ma main
et là c'est incroyable ça ça fait
flipper les enfants ça faut pas se faire
aux enfants ça les fait tuer j'en
connais un autre a été mais avec les
doigts aller ailleurs et vous voyez mes
index j'ai passé mon index gauche vous
êtes à l'envers là mais pour moi c'est
rigolo je passais mon index gauche à
droite juste par un autre choc de même
moi je dis qu'il ya un montage vidéo si
vous voulez suivre raphaël callandreau
vous inquiétez pas il a pas de facebook
il a pas twitter je cite un site
internet mais ça myspace à bercy cela
donc vous inquiétez pas si vous n'avez
pas aimé ce qu'il a fait une de leur
fourrage jamais téléphone à clapet des
vendeurs et ben c'est l'heure de vous
laisser du coup merci amoureux fou à
bâle de rien ah bon on s'embrasse jamais
embrassé en cinq ans mais qui membres à
faire voilà parce que je ne sais pas si
avant j'allais porter une moustache on
peux te retrouver dans le spectacle de
guillaume d'arnaud vanhelle germaneau
motion en alternance avec guillaume
nocture keira d'autres musiciens
oui ouistes est en fait ils accompagnent
en live cet artiste sur scène qui fait
de l'impro un one man show d'intro très
particulier on va vous en parler demain
enfin on va on est une équipe de 10
personnes va bien je vais vous en parler
demain comme un galet qui même sous sol
est allé le voir je vais les voir ce
soir c'était c'était vraiment chouette
et du coup ça habille vraiment le fait
que tu pas fait ces délais que tu façon
c'était derrière un piano quoi servent
ils merci beaucoup pour ça vous abonner
à la chaîne on est plus en plus nombreux
et ça c'est ouf
abonnez vous venez me voir en spectacle
aussi fabien olicard beau mentaliste je
suis je non j'étais parce que ça c'est
un donc du coup je suis bientôt à
mulhouse les prochaines dates de tournée
c'est à elles sont à mulhouse à
l'entrepôt théâtre pour trois jours donc
venez me voir là bas comme ça on fait
une vidéo après c'est super cool
venez aux hallucinations collectives et
autres illusions fantastique je peux
vous dire qu'il ya du lourd
et cet homme ne sera pas programmé
quoique sinon on se dit c'est pas
possible qu'on ait vu ça c'est pas
possible qu on a tout dit et bien rendez
vous demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mondial blog charest